I think back to all the parties that I
went to growing up and to be totally
honest I definitely didn't know anything
about football so the fun part of it for
me was watching the fun commercials the
technology is amazing they're using this
badass lady who's my stunt double and
they're putting my face on her so it
looks like I'm actually the badass lady
I mean Adele gave me as many catch
pointers as I can handle which is not
probably enough to become a pro football
player but I must say I caught the ball
one-handed a few times so it's just
making me feel pretty great bikini-ready
um well I just got back from vacation
and I think just you know being like in
the water and being really active all
the time when you're on vacation makes
even when you're eating a crazy amount
of food you end up losing weight
sometimes on vacation but yeah I think
yoga hiking that kind of stuff for me it
works really well I'm totally excited
for my family to see it I think my dad
especially will appreciate it the new
cascada is amazing I love that there's a
convertible Buick I think it's really
cool can I believe it's a Buick
I am completely surprised it's a Buick